with over 300 sessions at next 2023 it's
understandable that you couldn't get
them all so if you didn't see generative
Ai and search Better Together to unlock
Enterprise data then stay tuned because
here's the
rewind information Discovery is still
unsolved and we've all experienced the
impact of that especially in the
Enterprise space with data grow
exponentially information is distributed
across multiple clouds devices apps and
so is the workforce remote and hybrid
workers have made information retrieval
even more critical and yet most users
can't easily find what they're looking
for which makes the dream of having the
Google search experience for your
internal data and realtime agile
decision-making nearly impossible and
the Enterprise challenges don't stop
there productive time is is wasted
looking for documents data and answers
and when it's found there's a lack of
confidence in the accuracy of the search
results and the potential for
duplication of effort as there's no
single source of
Truth and time to First value is delayed
for new hirers who struggle with the
challenge of
onboarding siloed search departments
across functions increase overhead as do
growing storage compute and network
traffic
costs and while the adoption of
generative AI is a step forward it's not
enough search 1.0 was heavily based on
keywords connectors and content you
needed to know the right words to search
for or the right people to ask and
search 2.0 was the age of semantics
speed and generation or knowing what you
need and describing it
well and for the companies that have
adopted generative AI strategies for
information Discovery there have been
noted improvements such such as
vectorization of sources summarization
of information across the multiple
sources conversation beyond the initial
search to get more specific answers and
connections with inherited metadata and
even permissions to create better search
experiences but there are still valuable
elements that are missing like
personalization that goes beyond your
role and into preferences habit and
intent of your search or perception that
enables Discovery where you might not
even know what you need to find and
extensibility that goes beyond a summary
with information in a widget or a tile
and action orientation that closes the
loop on your search without needing to
go to a new window or anywhere
else so that leaves a lot of opportunity
for search 3.0 a boundaryless discovery
with personalization awareness and
actions so you not only get what you
need but learn new relevant things along
the
way search 3.0 will be the true
realization of AI with more data not
just from humans but also reliably
machine generated regardless of where it
resides integrated with new technologies
and with results delivered in a new more
helpful way meeting your users where
they are and also getting them where
they need to be or even connected to
other teammates for
expertise vertex AI search and
conversation brings so much more to the
Enterprise search experience generative
search with llms multi-turn
conversational search natural language
search and results capabilities with
autocomplete spell check and tuning for
synonyms or results relevancy and
grounding citations and safe search so
you can trust your results along with
connectors to thirdparty sources for the
data that your users need and we're only
getting started with deeper
personalization analytics Advanced
tuning and reasoning and even more if
you'd like to see the full talk check
out the link in the description and
don't forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for
watching